if you were searching for a hidden gem
buried within a streaming slush pile you
could do a lot worse than lock out a
2012 masterwork a French science fiction
that's currently burning up the charts
at Netflix when Netflix release said top
10 lists this week viewers were
surprised to find the underappreciated
foreign film assuring the strong 8th
place as of May 19th
lockout breach the streamers most viewed
lists joining the ranks of hotly
anticipated Netflix originals like the
wrong Missy and recognizable franchises
like Despicable Me the popular streamer
only recently lifted up its digital
curtain to make at least a tiny sliver
of their tightly held viewing statistics
public since earlier this year they've
been promoting a weekly top 10 of their
most watched content albeit without
revealing the actual numbers and the
results have definitely been interesting
so far the rankings have been dominated
by predictable mix of buzz worthy
original content and licensed properties
with broad family appeal films like
lockout surprised us when they cracked
the list because they don't fit
comfortably in either box so what
business is a little-known French film
from 8 years ago have climbing the ranks
to such heights as it turns out that
lockout is actually a pretty wild ride
and us viewers who likely missed its
original release have been there for the
2012 action film as a directorial debut
a French filmmakers James Mother and
Stephenson Lachey they hired luc besson
of The Fifth Element Fame to assist with
the screenplay though both mother and
son Lachey are also credited as writers
on lockout for a first foray the
greenhorn directors landed a pretty
blockbuster cast luck out stars Guy
Pearce as protagonist snow opposite
Maggie Grace as Emilie Warnock they're
joined by Vincent Regan Joseph Gilligan
Lennie James and Peter Stormare PSS snow
is a man framed for a crime he didn't
commit in a far future world he is
offered the opportunity to earn his
freedom if he rescues a president's
daughter Emily played by grace from a
notorious orbital prison known as ms one
ms one has been taken over by a violent
gang of inmates in for revolts and emily
is currently their captive Gilligan and
Regan play Alex and hydel the inmate
ring leaders who engineer the prison
riots and take Emily as a bargaining
chip don't
it's a dream vacation I mean I I load up
I go into space I get inside the
maximum-security nuthouse save the
president's daughter if you think some
of these elements sound familiar
legendary sci-fi director John Carpenter
agrees you go in find the president
bring him out in 24 hours and you're a
free man
24 hours and make a new and author he
successfully sued mother and son Lachey
for plagiarizing the story of his
classic genre films escape from New York
and escape from LA Carpenter was
eventually awarded 20,000 euros for the
infringement in addition to that 10,000
euros awarded to screen rights in the
castle and the 50,000 euros awarded to
MGM an appeal of the decision was
rejected back in 2016
bringing the matter to a close
reasonable Minds can differ as to
whether the European Court ruled rightly
in this case it should be noted that
European intellectual property law tends
to be much more unforgiving than US law
while might qualify as an infringement
and the European system could be deemed
a tribute under the American paradigm if
mother and son Lachey were going to look
to older works for inspiration they
could do a lot worse than carpenters
films whether you consider it a ripoff
or a tribute the results on display in
lockout speak for themselves lockout was
originally released to 2308 theaters in
the United States in Canada over its
brief run it only made 14 million
dollars domestically
adding another 18 million dollars to
that total worldwide with that attitude
how can she way nobody liked come on we
beloved me
critical response was mixed at the time
though most reviewers lauded guy
Pierce's performance in the lead role of
snow Derrick Malcolm at the London
Evening Standard wrote that it's
laughably over the top of a PS a decent
actor and cos it's somewhere between
escape from New York and the
Transformers some critics speculated at
the time the lockout suffered from a
fluttering comparisons to carpenters
Snake Plissken movies but others saw
merits in what Martha and son Lachey was
trying to accomplish
Sarah Gopal at digital journal wrote for
a night of shameless entertainment and
explosions lockout as a winning choice
that seems to be exactly what Netflix
viewers are after eight years after the
film's initial release it appears that
streaming audiences have decided that
lockout deserves a second look and many
of them officially like what they
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]